je peste raffiné érotique
pourquoi c'est important quand on vend
des voitures des hôtesses érotique pour
vendre des voitures
bienvenue au salon de l'auto des
voitures des femmes deux indissociable
du salon depuis maintenant bien
longtemps
vous pouvez l'étanchéité de la r8 cette
jeune personne n'hésite pas à prendre un
bain de mousse dans le coffre avant dans
les années 60 bien là prêté le test
caressait délicatement les voitures dix
ans plus tard moins farouche elle
montait carrément sur le capot ici nous
approchons vraiment quelque chose qui
marque c'est le cas de le dire mais
quand on pouvait l'image qui tient sur
notre écran dans les années 80 ça va
encore plus loin
tout le monde va au salon cette grande
fête de l'automobile qui sera ouverte
jusqu'au dimanche 12 octobre au soir
face à l'eire poses équivoques sourire
enjôleur tout est fait pour faire rêver
ces messieurs et ça marche
la production car même si les hôtesses
du salon de l'auto ont fort heureusement
d'autres compétences que leur joli
sourire certains ne veulent pas y croire
quand je vous ferai pas je ferais pas
tellement confiance à un élément féminin
quand on pose des questions précises on
s'aperçoit que ça passe au dessus de la
tête le plus souvent l'image de la femme
objet réduite au rang de vitrine pour
attirer les acheteurs potentiels à la
vie dure et même en 2007
ça fait partie aussi du décorum du salon
de l'automobile le salon 2018 semble
ouvrir une nouvelle page de l'histoire
de l'événement automobile avec le label
mondial woman les organisateurs
souhaitent promouvoir le rôle des femmes
dans cet univers masculin
alors simple symbole ou véritable prise
de conscience l'avenir nous le dira
[Musique]